[Musique]
c'est un des points centraux de la fête
de la musique à versailles sur la place
du marché notre dame les groupes
défilent
avant le coc vides on a gagné un
tremplin qui s'appelle le vendredi du
rock
organisé par les jeunes de versailles
donc c'était une super occasion et nous
avait promis qu'on jouerait à la fête de
la musique à versailles et c'est le cas
cette année donc on est hyper content
d'être là ce soir ça nous permet de
partager avec les publics de partager
notre histoire de partager hommes nos
valeurs aussi d'une certaine manière et
c'est vraiment un jour en fait c'est un
pur moment c'est un truc qui reste en
nous et peu importe où est ce qu'on va
derrière on on prend et on est super
content déjà d'avoir fait ça ce soir
donc voilà au total six groupes pour des
créneaux de 45 minutes chacun et quand
on s'éloigne de la célèbre place les
ambiances se suivent dans la cité royale
ne se ressemblent pas
de telle manière que tout le monde peut
trouver la musique qui lui correspond
chaque année on en profite on se détend
c'est un petit moment de lâcher prise on
profite de des chaleurs et décompresser
après le travail on va faire un tour à
voir s'il ya des endroits qui nous
plaisent plus que d'autres s'il ya de la
place s'installer boire un verre on
verra en général c'est au feeling mais
on va sûrement peut-être faire un after
avec des amis chez nous finir la soirée
en beauté je pense ouais se balader
écoutez un peu toutes les musiques qui a
qui fait quoi des rues au restaurant en
passant par les nombreux bars versailles
est au complet jusqu'à la tombée de la
nuit et même bien après
[Applaudissements]